- I BS'd my way into
jobs that I didn't have
the experience to do, and pulled it off.
But I had to believe in myself
to BS my way into a job.
- There's no place for
patience in business.
Patience in life means things happen
slower than they could.
- The last thing you want to do
is open a bar because you like to drink.
That's like somebody into drugs
who becomes a pharmacist.
I mean, that's just.
(audience laughs)
- Hello Believe Nation,
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the major problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn from
Bar Rescue TV host and world-renowned
bar expert Jon Taffer,
and my take on his top
ten rules for success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best.
And as always guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something that really
resonates with you, please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired.
And when you write it down
it's more likely to stick
for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(swoosh sound)
(intense music)
- You wake up in the
morning, you're failing.
So you blame the president,
you blame congress,
you blame Greece, blame the euro.
Construction in the
street, it's the mayor, oh.
And you wake up in the morning
and you look in the mirror,
and you're not failing because
it's the other guy's fault.
Or it's the economy's fault.
But if you looked in the mirror
and said, "I'm failing because of me,"
you wouldn't like it
and you'd change that.
I believe the common
denominator of failure
in any business is excuses.
As long as you wake up
and blame poor sales
on the economy or an environment,
then you have no motivation
to make it better.
Because it's not your fault.
But in the worst economic environment,
four or five years ago in this country
that we've seen in our lifetimes,
there were people making a
lot of money, weren't there?
In the height of that
recession were people
selling advertising,
people opening restaurants,
people building businesses.
Somebody's making money,
so the excuse is bull.
It's bull.
So wake up in the morning
and own your failure.
Look in the mirror and say,
"I'm failing because of me."
And you won't like it.
And then you'll change it.
But as long as you don't put it on you,
you have no motivation to change it.
So in short, if you own your failure,
you'll own your success.
If you don't own your failure,
you'll never dig out.
I find that in any business;
always the common denominator of failure
personally is excuses.
You don't want to be a failure, do you?
- [Audience Member] Not at all.
- You don't want to look in the mirror
and experience that.
If you can't blame anybody but yourself,
you're going to change.
You're going to fight
it out, that's the deal.
I BS'd my way into jobs that I didn't have
the experience to do, and pulled it off.
But I had to believe in myself
to BS my way into a job.
When you were younger you didn't have
the producer experience you have now.
- No, but I always had the confidence
like I can do it, I'll figure it out.
- Exactly right, and I knew
I could figure it out too.
- [Evan] Right.
- And that gave me the confidence
to show up at the interview
and convince that guy
to hire me because I was convinced myself
that I could do it.
And that comes across.
Let me introduce you to
the concept of success.
Ben Franklin was a pretty smart guy,
and I want to start with a quote by him.
"If you do tomorrow what you did today,
"you will get tomorrow
what you got today."
You want to know what that means?
The average American makes between
three and five percent more each year.
That's the deal.
In today's economy, I'm not
sure we're going to make
the three to four to five percent
next year as employees.
So it takes you 20 years
to double your income
in America as an average person.
That's the mediocrity that
we're stuck in in life.
And then you meet people who have
the uncanny ability to double
their income in a year.
To get promoted five times in a year.
The ones that beat the system.
The ones that conquer it.
You've all seen them, haven't you?
The difference between them and the ones
that don't do that is that they wake up
in the morning, and
they think differently.
They understand that if i do tomorrow
what I did today, I'm
going to get tomorrow
what I got today.
You want a bigger car?
- How about a nice house in Tahiti?
Sherri, would you love a nice house
in the Hills?
We all want better things don't we?
We all want more friends,
more stuff, more money,
more security, more
travel, more enjoyment.
If you do the same thing tomorrow
that you did today, you're stuck.
Stuck.
And it doesn't change.
And it grows a little at a time.
And you get a taste of success,
but it's never fast enough.
It never excites you, and when it does
it's a good month.
Or a good two months,
or a good three months.
But it doesn't provide a trajectory
that creates success.
So the first thing I want you
to think about today,
is I want you to wake up
tomorrow and do something different.
Understand if you do the same damn thing,
you're stuck.
Just because you did it
a certain way yesterday
is no reason to do it that way today.
I want it to hit hard.
That's not what drives success, you do.
You do.
And you do.
When you go back tomorrow,
you'll either start counting
guests or you won't.
You'll either look at
your marketing budget
and split it up to new
frequency or expenditure
or you won't.
You'll either look at your staff
and get rid of the dead
weight that you know
is costing you money, or you won't.
And you'll look at your bar programs
and what to do, or you won't.
Everyone of you wrote the word action down
at least a few times, correct?
(audience agrees)
Do it.
You know I'm just not patient.
There's no place for patience in business.
Patience in life means things happen
slower than they could.
So if you're going to be on this planet
for 70 years and things happen slower
than they should, at the end of 70 years
you're going to have less, aren't you?
Less experiences, less time, less money,
less of everything.
So let's all hurry up, man,
and get more out of life.
That's my view.
- So patience is not a--
- Am I crazy?
(audience applauds)
If you think your life is complete,
then I suggest that you're an ass.
Because tomorrow always has
a great opportunity in it.
Your life is not complete
until you close your eyes.
So when you say somebody
who's in a job they hate
would love to be able to do this,
my comment is why the hell
are you in a job you hate?
Don't you have the courage to leave it?
So you're in a job you hate,
you're doing nothing to change it,
but you'd like better?
You have to do better.
- Sometimes if they have mouths to feed,
sometimes I get it.
But what were the things about you?
Listen, we'd have to go over those
specific cases I think,
and really getting into
each person to break them.
But what do you think
were the things about you?
One of it is you always had your eyes
open to tomorrow and new opportunities.
What were some of the other things
as part of your personality,
because there aren't many people like you,
but I've seen and I'm
studying more and more people
where amazing things are
happening at 55 and 60,
and putting them on life journeys
that they never thought
they were going to have.
And I'm seeing that you guys
have a lot of the similar
attributes, but what do you think?
What was it about you, Jon?
- Courage.
Courage.
The first time I went and shot a pilot
for Bar Rescue, it was really hard.
You think it's easy to scream at people
on national television?
To insult people on national television?
To call you a jerk,
challenge your marriage,
challenge your integrity,
challenge your professionalism?
That's hard.
That's not who I am.
I don't wake up and embarrass people
in front of their friends.
- [Evan] Right.
- In front of their family.
Bar Rescue is the hardest
work I have ever done.
The courage that it takes
for me to go out there
and do these things.
When I was in my young 20s
I was managing expenses,
managing marketing budgets,
and faced a lot of the
problems that you did.
My labor cost was too
high, so I'm shaving hours.
My marketing expense is too high,
so I'm shaving dimes.
I can't give stuff away,
I have less dollars for entertainment.
Suddenly my rent is expensive,
my occupancy cost is expensive,
my taxes are expensive.
And I'm just focused on the fact
that everything is expensive.
Then somebody came into my business
and taught me how to do a promotion.
Literally a month later,
my revenues went up 30%.
In a month.
When I looked at my PNL,
I didn't have a labor cost problem.
The numbers worked.
Suddenly I had a few
dollars for marketing.
I could actually buy some stuff.
I had money for new paint on the walls,
and I realized that day
we don't have expense
problems in any business.
All we have are revenue problems.
Revenue is the cure-all;
that's the asprin you take every night
to feel better in the morning
is revenue, revenue, revenue.
You got to wake up in the
morning and drive revenue,
which means you got to have
the promotions, the ideas,
the energy to elevate a business.
You got to be a rainmaker in business,
or you're never going to get anyone wet.
And when they don't get wet,
they dry up and go away.
It's that wetness of a rainmaker
that filters down and trickles
to everybody's success.
You have to drive the energy of revenue
to be successful, and when you do,
you'll have no expense problems.
Anybody see the Murphy's
episode of Bar Rescue?
The two frat brothers who opened a bar?
- Yeah.
- The last thing you want to do
is open a bar because you like to drink.
That's like somebody into drugs
who becomes a pharmacist.
I mean, that's just.
(audience laughs)
It makes no sense at all.
You got to do it for the right reasons,
You got to do it because
you love the business.
If you love the social aspect of it,
you'll never do your financials,
you'll just hang with people all day long.
If you love the drinking,
that's even worse.
You got to love the business,
it's a tough business.
We were talking before we started.
In a clothing store
business, you buy shirts,
you mark them up 60, 70%.
If you've got ten shirts on the shelf,
you go home that night, you come back
in the morning and you
still got ten shirts
on the shelf.
Not the bar business.
Bar business, you've go
to manage every minute.
Right product is exposed,
liabilities are exposed.
It's a tough business.
Honestly, if I had to do it over again,
I'm not sure I would be in this business.
To be honest with you,
when I look at all the work
that I did over the years,
I could have applied those efforts
to bigger things rather than smaller bars.
I was involved in
Rainforest Cafe for example.
That went public and that was big dollars.
Don't get me wrong, I don't regret
being in a bar business,
but when I look at my life,
all the nights that I
worked, all those evenings,
days, 20-hour days, I look back and say,
"Gee, what if I'd have been a lawyer?"
Nah, maybe not a lawyer.
(audience laughter)
There are lifestyles that
are easier is my point.
So you got to love the
business and be passionate
about it to make it
through those late nights
and those mornings.
I have a dear friend who
works for a large company
and he wants to open a franchise,
buy a franchise, of sandwich stores.
I won't say which brand.
He wants to buy it with a territory.
He meets with me and he says,
"Jon I need some advice,
"do I leave my long-standing
job and benefits and do this?"
So why can't you have
your cake and eat it too?
- [Evan] Right.
- Why can't you bring in a partner,
why can't you bring in somebody to do it?
There's ways to get there.
It doesn't have to be absolute.
If somebody wants to create a 2nd career,
create new opportunities in their life,
figure out a way to do it
without risking what you have.
- [Evan] Right.
- And if you want it enough,
you'll figure it out.
Everything that we do
is reaction management.
If you can make your bosses
react the way you want them to,
you're going to get a
promotion aren't you?
You're going to get that job you want.
How do you get them to
react to you in a way
that gets you promoted?
When you figure that
out, you'll get promoted.
That's reaction management.
It's understanding that those reactions
that happen around you drive your future
more than you do.
The only final advice I would give you
is I've lived a very unconventional life,
and it's because I live
my dream every day.
Dreams are inspiring, work is not.
Find a dream.
Whether it's that client you can't get
that you've been fighting
for for six months.
You've got to have dreams.
Dreams make this world go on,
it built our whole country.
And when we get in a rut as human beings,
is when we lose touch with our dreams.
We lose the ability to
fight for those dreams.
So don't be an employee of Google.
Live your dreams at Google.
Find the way to match your dreams
with the goals of your
company in your own work.
Because there's nothing worse
than mechanical employees that lost touch
with their dream.
The worst thing in the
world is when you see
somebody who lost touch with their dreams.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because Shredder Steve
asked me to.
So if there's someone
you'd like me to cover
in the next top ten,
please check out the link
in the description so
you can cast your vote.
I also want to give a quick shout-out
to Tanya Jackson.
Tanya, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word" and posting
that awesome picture on Twitter.
I really, really appreciate it
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(zoom sound followed by explosion)
- I drive quality as a leader,
my systems maintain quality.
Now with regard to new projects,
to me, every new project is a ball.
I have to move that ball every day.
So I know, for example,
that I have four balls
on my desk.
They might be five pads.
Let's say five balls on my desk.
They might be five different pads,
five different books,
five different projects.
Every day I'm going to
move those five balls.
That's the way I live my life,
and I can't go to sleep
at night if I don't move
every one of those five balls every day.
Sometimes I have three balls,
sometimes I have seven balls,
but the amount of balls that I accept
and put on my desk, every one of them
is going to move forward every day.
And I become relentless.
I've learned to live my life based upon
the progress I make on a daily basis.
And I believe that business is defined
by what we do every day, every single day.
And business is defined
by the days that we have.
So if you move those five balls every day,
you can't help but be successful.
You will achieve it,
but you'll achieve it on a daily basis.